we know all about reality TV shows like
Dance Moms they highlight all the bad
stuff and leave all humility at the
front door isn't that right girls we've
seen you pull tantrums shed tears point
fingers in each other's faces and really
fight them off but is that really how
things go down behind the scenes we
highly doubt it despite all the mama
drama and useless fights we're sure you
guys had a lot of fun filming Dance Moms
and we're going to prove it it's easy to
forget that the Dance Moms cast is
filled with people just like us sure
they have their dramatic moments but
they share some funny and heartfelt ones
too we've got plenty of
behind-the-scenes moments coming your
way so don't go anywhere let's kick
things off with a Dance Moms elite squad
throwback video we're so used to seeing
the dancers stressing out over their
performances that we forget that they
get plenty of time to just be kids
here's a behind-the-scenes video of
Chloe Nia Kendall and Paige goofing
around with the other girls from the
ALDC Kendall might come off as one of
the more serious and cutthroat dancers
but in reality she's super silly and fun
the show just doesn't highlight her best
qualities look at how much fun Kendall
is having with one of her fellow dancers
they're goofing around with the
jellyfish handshake it's easy to forget
that Abby Lee Miller has an entire
school of students but this clip helps
us remind us that the Dance Moms crew
isn't all the rhibs the original girls
are super close to their classmates and
they have so much fun behind the scenes
it's no secret that Maddie does super
hilarious can any of you guess what
Maddie is saying in this clip leave your
answer in the comments we love these
behind the scenes clips because we get
to see just how small our favorite
dancers used to be look how tiny
Mackenzie is Chloe is holding on her
phone and filming her friends she's
testing out her new Instagram app they
might have hectic schedules but there's
plenty of time to goof around it might
seem like light years ago but vine used
to be a thing and it made its way into
the ALDC here's a hilarious clip of
Maddie and Nia doing it for the vine
Maddie and Kendall used to be BFFs but
now they're more like acquaintances
still this video warms our hearts and
reminds us of how things used to be
check out Maddie and Kendall's karate
handshake it's hilarious next up we see
the girls holding hands and skipping
their way around the mat this is
surefire way to loosen up and to get
into the groove and it's a whole lot of
fun too who wouldn't want to dance to
Mariah Carey's classic Christmas Carol
have you ever wondered how the girls
from the ALDC managed to nail their
somersaults flips and pirouettes well it
takes a lot of practice here's a clip of
the girls learning how to do flips jumps
and other tricks now that's something we
don't see on Dance Moms Maddie and Nia
are wonderful dancers and we love it
when they perform numbers together but
check out this crazy stunt that they're
trying to pull off now that's impressive
Dance Moms is a place for fun goes to
die writes well not technically
the girls have plenty of time to create
fun memories like this one check out
Mackenzie she's trying to master the
ever so tricky hoverboard Mackenzie's
hoverboard soon catches Kendall's
attention and despite being in rehearsal
she gets on top of it and twirls around
and just when we thought she was a
natural she almost wiped out soon it's
Maddie's turn to try the hoverboard and
she's so scared she's shaking
not that we blame her though those
things are seriously unpredictable soon
Kendall jumps in to help her friend only
to start joking around with her next up
we see Maddie putting on the show for
the juniors when she's done she pulls
her dance teacher to the floor and tries
to get him to Nene he tries to get on
board but seems to feel a little awkward
so he gets someone to change the music
and start dancing the Macarena Maddie
looks comfortable and happy in these
behind-the-scenes moments in fact the
entire cast seems to be living their
best life we loved the original Dance
Moms squad but now it's time to take a
look at what's going on behind the
scenes of season 8 in this season a
behind-the-scenes moment we see Hannah
Colin and her mother and as they
rehearse the choreography to the last
unicorn that's why you're here
this scene shows us just how dedicated
an is when it comes to perfecting our
daughter's technique are you guys
watching season eight of Dance Moms if
so tell us how you feel about the new
season in the comments section but first
check out this heartfelt moment the new
cast recently shared it's very rare for
the producers of Dance Moms to show
their faces on camera but in this
behind-the-scenes footage we see the
ALDC celebrating Bryan Stinson's
birthday we even see Abby Lee Miller in
the backgrounds and all the other dance
moms hanging out without feeling the
need to bicker amongst each other at
first glance it's easy to judge Dance
Moms and label its cast as dramatic
ruthless and stressed out but once you
dig a little deeper you find out that
everyone's having a blast most of the
time are you a huge Dance Moms fan if so
tell us who your favorite og dancer is
and be sure to tell us who your new
favorite dancer from season 8 is to
sound off in the comments section for
more awesome behind the scenes videos
about your favorite shows subscribe to
the things and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching we'll catch you next time
[Music]